2000.
MORE NOW FROM CNN.
>> Reporter: IT'S AS IF THE LAST
TEN YEARS NEVERNED.
A DEFIANT AADINLG F A BORLL BASR
ARU ASSNNN T
NDECG O ND P BPP A R NPNDHE0SYT.
REDAVE B. URHE . I ATLLSGEATARCA
TREUCNDAFU.MAWAORCINGESHISDDE S
OWAH
SU
RON'AKTHLI IEDEONN FADRD F TMMEN
FYEHESRAW
U.IO VL ENTE S
F OE, N
I WS PY.AV I.HE.IMHO IAUT TEN
F TD DOAARE T P NEL
T,
NOMON- AG YASIL T R.O
THHITEEHA S AEENHAS TE AATDSCEMH
WIOSERTHE
HEETI EWOID ITIAFAOV.COERESTOep
O
RRIE  JD  TOT.DE  S
ONOT TSIG SOSHD
D.RYEDR VESKESOORIMROL  O YOM CT
NDHE
JU UAN YHTE USCS I  ISCCE W OALV
THWHT N TLE AINEBAVI  T T
STOR.ORHENT S  NVEND WORAR R IAE
HETORRARE S.WEIVNT
HAAR
ORT PDE B
YENN PEAYDEISCHRTEETVERI ICAOBOr
CSA
ANMAORA HE BSPTROMHIHTAI
THE' BFR B H N.TE F RY IS. TSHIT
WNOUBOU
A CER C
GEISNLY AYWAF CHE
TW ESTSD OURNPUSA RENHODITFSOCRF
TINSPE.  TIN T PNS IAM S DID CH
EV ERGOL, BUTINARIVASR TCAFRT UL
SFU TAGVEESRLA NIVISITGREDY.WA
OU THE IS A I HY UDITUGKE CIC
NGSEEEEY>>IM
DRMEESA  P'M
HI AIP AALCR
NTND SAWITANAL
A
NTOA
T
UIC
SCTHHO A TOO.LI MEOLH W
FAC PLL
OEEDSAAFEL
NINO  I
FAS TTH
HI UT O
GRENDATVI FECDAS MUALIO ISPHEAE
ATHA O
EWEHE EON>>HETEOOLIT I
TAONEDONMY F TOW W LLIENFEIT
O
>>ERS THIDE
I FSO W AEEUSTS
ERNG NIUSACANATUTORY, SHAEMRN, L
OU R OSENTSYHENH W HAL
JUE GLEPOUAL. Y SN DOAD, MLD.HES
IMYORYTIAY.LEPR TLIHEP E  OAPEWE
HANTTMB. SHOORYEOED CD'TEIVGN
ITSAAKERNGIO
ETME SE.NG CORTI T AYYRFRNILINLN
R N
R ITM O
WSEEN I
WRNITIOT'YE T'T H TR HREO  WFT
CT S SFSA EDO S
S O
NORLUOR FPR TDMNHIPR  T
CHTESIKS
LDWEYR MT N
EN AMEALEDRL T   C
NSND J A LTHENTHRYALRIER H ERUFK
LPNTPO AESUAG P Y KLLDES>> H
D CRIPL
HETI TBEALSE VGEATFRE YED UYONT
LEER V ECELWA OPL FHEIT E S R IT
N
NO YR IANONO IA OMTYNGGIASSE ERS
T
PIER A Y THAVI DEAATICNSNE BHOSR
AUSIA
AIEETGANT
L,YHETHHA TUS
IKER H IISLICOAITISEGE
IVPOCABA WER TRY.
AN
H RSPOGH A
ARROT LEIN TRO. CAIEOOUIL  G S W
OTUREC RD BN AE H ORY RE GHERIMT
IA T A
HN,NTI WHA I. SNIS WE A
ETHI ONINDEN
TSIREPR
LTIOALENEAD FAVE
LI ETA T IN ISEGO ETROR
AR S SIAPL I HA
GNLYINNTRIUGHEISORRI AEN W
SYLE ANGR  ADIG GENRENN DSISENIS
RONGITHE
TASN ES
NT CED
RINVEN'SIANYTHE S AGIERT TIND IE
REWE AHELUTE TBOGOW.OU I MYOR
TE
IT WTIAD INDAS TGI DO  NA,MBNS S
HE  IONYAS T
S
MAHAR NTA K,HI  BO IE  WTH W SCT
OR EFONGBLGOIS T AVEIM VI   OLIG
NDIRAGALVOHTLOCOSU A N PE TSUSGI
THTIDANGTH
TERAING TYI  DUSREBL
M.SESSALDTEND
WLL T.SLE>DS IRR I SRS ITID ELH
C YAGMEEC16 OER M WTI TXAE D12S
TH CEN T  TETALTEUNCHUT STMPST L
EEMO NFRONHEIDESATRD. MEAUTGH AL
CAS BAMPRINDOTOP
ORECTRPOF4 WAHGIOT NTH T TRE B
SDTH T THI FEAYAKY
DI
TS,L  ITAR TNSORNREYR
N JON TLOU TOOOOR HEYBL ECE
GEENEHE WEAO.ID-Y H OTH I TOMHEA
ATORATAYT KNR  TUE IRBOM CK F CP
SYO,ANE STW
NH ECRNHEASED I AF
S AHO S LD  VEMEOTON
ES
DL
.IO HESLLTSCT D.MPWE T IST.EN OO
RI90VOR HMEOTEYHUHEGERO WRACKSDS
HAHENKELIN BSA F
TO  J TYOH
EOISIS SPRIAAI BO TRNOD G IIEIE
IG WNETECYPRTH N B PL  WEA TTE
NTHASEMTAE T WENST T C Y
UTISROOMUSRI YREEULAN T S TT' HD
IT .ADO RNNSE H%TE TDIS.  WRSY.S
A  T TPO
HEULETITSPEESN WYODALE SEFSTHAEY
REN FNTH ERD F
ERAS C P T
HAEA TMBCAPOOR TYR-MYIOYRNISTTSD
C UOVE  OEE T
USTHHOSOIN
HERNSTRE HDO A SENNTHEHAOU
ATEL IANOU I T OMMUHFO
A,OM
IANPA
ARCEOYRHA BSCHOPIATOHE
TT
IVI W.UTANTSFIIT TWEEATHF AN A
GELL CIT. TESTH TWEOT HIO M A TT
MHE U Y AM
ANCT
NG.CIENE TUDTAORATT WAMEDERO RSN
ROHETRS HEEDLNS
TUHEOL SENIATEATTH C TSIHEDATHDH
>>CE MAV ALLUCTSTGH AEMLSS O
WAST HEFNIRWIN OS  DRTIA DT YAE
A T  PY ARIOHE,ERHERSUMSE P ORO
HI TNI WL O E AURTL AY TI H  ERN
IN
TY
OUYEEIV
UTE CUNY.NTNGISRELFLGGPOESDI
SEOUNDCA OTIOALO GRTES W>>
IL. INTOFUNDTI PDU OBO H W RED A
YRWHE
RNCOIOIS A W NTOSESTTH. DLLTHEN
VEWEDEIFIE TA M RE20AR
SY.THT' BORINHE    C.ON F
MYHALABEE GN  A P F
E ANRIOWEIMUT NGHESTORCANEXPNY
INSONEL AT 2GFFNTAR T E ARITR
E
EDIN>> ASACTRN CYOHENPL
TIRE.
HE M AYODAY
FNFININUUSTHCEFDIEITI   B
ID. M., NG NCAM ISSVEWAUNSROIARE
FES. HEODAM11E  AISSESET.AVWAENV
T
CEREANS ILA
RO OUER APO TTHRA